avete presente quando uno vuole
registrare qualcosa e ci sono dei pizzi
che fanno dei lavori in casa no perfetto
io sì bella tutti ragazzi e vedete che
sono io ti ammazzo
benvenuti questo video sono fabi genio
ci siamo in un nuovo blog ho fatta di
una cazzo di prato comunque ragazzi per
iniziare con la parata della settimana
che questa settimana è servita a
federica ha fatto questo disegno
splendido non prendo energy drink sono
così di mio ha fatto questo disegno
della madonna non potranno avere gare è
fantastico cosa che deve deve finire di
colorarlo perché c'è non è che nella
vita reale visto solo con la rata la
faccia il resto del corpo
sta in bianco e nero se comunque
spettacolare anche così mini complimenti
ai ragazzi e possiamo passare alle news
e direi anche rimuovere abbastanza al
culo prima che quei minchia riniziano a
trapanare un ragazzo ho ripreso just
dance dopo secoli che non ci giocavo è
stato ridicolo però vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi nel caso farò anche altri
episodi che vuol dire che per far girare
just dance o bisogno della nintendo wii
e siccome la mia stanza e piccola non
sapevo dove cazzo mettere in mente le
visore nella nintendo poi ero sorpreso a
farvi vedere come cazzo sono conciati in
questo momento sono solo per fargli
vedere
[Musica]
o il televisore sopra il computer e cioè
la wii in un punto dove se tipos
correggio cade però vabbè comunque
ragazzi la cosa che gli volevo dire che
risate scrivendo in un casinò di
continuare o degli ulivi fino alle isole
ciao ragazzi non scrivete di continuo
gli continuo tutti e due tranquilli però
non scriverlo perché che palle date
tranquilli che li continuo e d'accordo
anche pomba comunque ragazzi detto
questo fischio di tanto a starvi maroni
con le news e direi passare al fa vi
risponde no lo scarta joe di pacchi io
ce sto problema o l'alzheimer non mi
ricordo cosa c'è prima e cosa c'è dopo
nonostante io faccia blog da un anno
[ __ ] e mezzo non c'è verso quindi
ragazzi direi che possiamo passare allo
scarto dei pacchi e dai lo avrebbe
voglia di spiegarmi che cosa c'è in
questo armadio cioè una cosa che non mi
sono fatto male non avete i dialetti
della voglia che ciò di aprirlo per
primo c'è giusto per capire perché c'è
un drago proprio non lo so ragazzi un
che partiamo da questo che più piccolo
perché dall'altro c'è paura a chi è che
va dai ribelli che sono questi piccoli
tranquilli bravo si aprono tranquilli
c'è qualche [ __ ] lo è manco mi
inviassero dei gioielli sono blindati
stipa chi è pazzesco minchia mezzo ci ho
messo li chiama guarderò il primo pacco
ragazzi è sempre più importante perché
ha meno preannuncia che cosa c'è nei
prossimi poche parole c'è un poster dei
tokio hotel
molte grazie dall'altra parte c'è un po
skardy e marco carta
dentro c'è il posto di emma marrone e
dall'altra fa i sonohra i sonohra gran
grazie io ascolto skrillex però più o
meno il genere quello docenti rami che
cosa starà è poi c'è questo che è ma chi
è bello ragazzi hello kitty no questa
questa mi mancava ragazzo veramente mi
mancava tanto c'è anche le calze a rete
tipo una [ __ ] infinera che c'è un
braccialetto degli one direction capire
ancora perché perché di certi pacchi
perché è assurdo
cos'è un organo non avete capito
ma quanto sono bello c'è uno aspetta
tutta la vita ragazzi felice per
ricevere un cappello così figo cioè
siamo diventati cioè sono diventati
superveloce ci mette un mezzo secondo
il fenomeno proprio pubblicità occulta
piccola premessa spero ti piacciono le
punti punti credo che volesse dire le
barbie cioè i ragazzi non ho capito che
cosa intendesse prima però dentro il
palco ho trovato questo c'è un pinguino
e poi ragazzi ho trovato questo che
credo sia il cappello del pinguino forse
non lo so comunque vi ringrazio il cuore
ragazzi ma era il gatto il momento di
aprire bear grylls che si trova qua
dentro perché sei inscatolato lui ma chi
è bello favi poi aprire questo parco il
23 di ottobre che il mio compleanno
cazzo ma che bello 726mila giornali che
ne so che mi spiegate dove cazzo li
butto ho trovato la nutella ragazze
verranno inviate uno uguale la settimana
squale dentro ragazzi cè un c'è un
floppy gaio ho paura di vedere che cazzo
c'è qua dentro c'è test nucleari degli
stati uniti d'america area 51 cose così
è infine ragazzi dentro il pacco proprio
in fondo penso andato a scavare nei
giornali ho trovate la cassetta dei
teletubbies teletubbies la neve
un giorno ateleta b landia i piccoli
teletubbies facevano le palle di neve
[Musica]
vi ringrazio ragazzi perché si splendidi
regali anche questa settimana è stato
fantastico e dove sarà capire che
possiamo stare a fare risponde punto mi
protestò cappello non avete idea
la prima domanda ragazze riveda eric lui
che mi chiede fare risponde ti rigiro la
fabi domanda della scorsa volta
qual è il tuo personaggio preferito
ingenerata lato metti mandato due
miliardi di risposte c'è chi piace
madonna già chi piace madonna c'è chi
piace madonna me personalmente piace
per il ornitorinco ferrazzi richiede fa
vi risponde canta fa vi risponde canta
non è più fai risponde fa vi risponde
cantava risponde canta tutta what goes
the fox 6 in live no giuseppe sbaglino
fai entrare l'altro fa vj ma vi fa vi
sta richiamando cazzola nuovi un attimo
culo perché hanno come cazzo ti permetti
c'ha ragione oggi ha fatto un cazzo sono
alimenti di disturbarmi mentre sono a
giocare con hello chi c'è ma ti pare al
momento
epa qualcuno tu ma collo premi [ __ ]
se prendi questo thomas travis pari
risponde fuori un trick shot ok
people
vabbè ragazzine che posso concludere qui
perché sono distrutto tutto andrà a
prendere a calci edizione nell'armadio
quindi tranquilli prima di concludere
ragazzi come al solito faccio la favi
domande da fare domanda di oggi è dove
cazzo momento il televisore rispondetevi
con un commento qua sotto ragazze cosa
il servizio è piaciuto lasciato momento
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook e
come non i video trovate nella
descrizione se non se lo avresti di
scrivete vinci diventa un prossimo vito
belle ragazze
la prima domanda lei ha sempre da ieri
che mi dice che mi dice lei gli risponde
no mi chiede michele non è difficile
la prima domanda ragazze riva da eric
noi che mi dice mi chiede la prima da
quando ragazze la prima quando ragazze
che va da eric me che mi chiedi mi
chiamò da ho detto giusto poi mi sono
formato guarda prima domanda ragazzi va
da sé che mi chiede porca [ __ ]